They're trying to use anti-Semitism as a cudgel against Hasan.
That is what is
>> No. Stop. Stop saying it to Stop saying incredibly things,
please, for the love of God. >> Not my problem. How do
people watch this guy? How do people watch? How do they watch?
How do they watch?
Okay. So, Tim Miller, if you guys missed it yesterday, we're
going to cover the Hutch reaction to yesterday's video anyway.
So, Tim Miller basically came out and said, "We're going to have
a big tent and I like Hasan on Israel. Hasan actually does like
a good job of explaining why Israel's bad and people want passion
on Israel and all of this, right?" So, if we ever get to a point
where there's a Hasan-style candidate running for president and
there's more of like a, you know, sent a more traditional liberal
candidate running in a Democratic primary, I will be for more
of the traditional liberal candidate, right? Obviously. And we
can fight fight that out. But like my main thing about right
now about this Hasan discourse is like none of that's happening
right now. None of that's happening right now. The only reason
we're talking about Hasan is because other members ostensibly
of the anti-Trump coalition have tried to turn him into a litmus
test and say that people can't be seen with him. Candidates can't
be seen with him. And like I find that to be insane for a number
of reasons. Number one, I think the timing on that is awful.
Okay? All of our energy right now, if you're a four-level democracy,
if you're against Trump, if you think what's going on in this
country is bad right now, all of our energy should be laser-focused
on undermining this regime and bringing in more people who are
potentially opponents of the regime and adding them to our numbers,
right? There's strength in numbers. Whether that be at the No
Kings protest, whether that be at the midterms this coming year,
whether that be in 2028, like we need as many people as possible
to brush back this threat that I believe seriously is an existential
threat to the country. That's me. He was talking about how basically
on Israel Democrats need to start leaning into that. It's important,
And then he he came out and in response to some of the criticism
says, "I'm devastated to report that lots of Trump and Bibi supporters
believe that I have betrayed my principles for arguing that Dems
should be reaching out to the anti-war left and not shutting
them in this moment. I will look inside and reflect. I must admit
that on the
this seems like a convenient thing to be mad about to avoid reckoning
with the historic disaster that is Trump and Bibi's Iran war
and the coming wreckage for the global economy and the GOP that
is going to result." Say, "Luckily for Tim, there is zero remaining
Trump / Bibi supporters that understand what having principles
means. These are all These are like These are like blind people
telling you that you shouldn't wear that outfit, right? Hey,
they're totally blind and they're going, "That outfit is
Bro, you are basing this on something that you can't even identify.
You literally can't see. You can't see the thing you're talking
about. Why are you talking about it? Lot of crying under that
tweet? I bet there is. I bet there
Tim spends, if you don't remember the video, Tim spends the first,
I don't know, 15, 20 minutes of the video, maybe 10 minutes of
the video, basically saying like this is why I think Hasan could
be bad. This is the things I don't like about Hasan. And then
he goes into the rest of it, okay? had a on a number of ways,
but if you're only talking about a country with 9 million people
like Israel,
and you don't spend very much time at all talking about
other much bigger countries that are doing, you know, sometimes
even worse things, then it starts to get a little strange. Which
one? Which one? Which one? Which one's doing even worse
Which one? Which one's been doing even worse things for a longer
period of time, Hutch? Which one? Which one? Which one? Which
one? Which one? Which one Which one?
Then it starts to get a little Pull up the Israel versus Russia
table. Not right now. And Russia is not as bad. I'm sorry. Per
capita But the population thing doesn't save you. The little
population thing makes it worse that Oh, they've got such a little
population. Why are you going after them? They're just a small
bean. How is the small bean doing this much evil? How? a little
weird. It's like why is Israel the only thing being talked about
here? Like you can't be a gay Christian or, you know, in any
of those countries or Athei- You know what I mean? Like you can't
go into Saudi Arabia. I didn't realize how drunk Tim was for
He was slurring a lot during this. I didn't even realize it all.
and and expect to have equal rights, you know, if you're whatever,
if you're Buddhist or gay, right? There like So,
that is true of a lot of countries. It's a fair criticism of
Israel. I I think that there is a belief sometimes Hey, dude.
Israel's literally ethnically just ethnically cleansed like a
million people in Lebanon. And people are like, "It just seems
weird that you're talking about Israel right now." Like what's
the what's the half-life on Israel doing some sort of like nefarious
evil thing? How long do we have to Or how long can we complain
about it? Like it just seems odd that you guys are focused on
Israel right now. They keep doing evil shits. Semitism that likes
that Israel gets singled out because there's an anti-Semitic
subtext. So, that was what we were kind of addressing. Um my
my subject of critiques with
which I shared with him on that stage and off. We talked for
a long time in the green room. It's simp for China.
I I like I I I just don't like China is a repressive authoritarian
state that's we're fighting here. Very bad. Very bad what they
do in China. Very bad. And I think at times he's very he's much
too favorable to China for my taste. I can understand
why they make why they'd make people uncomfortable. For example,
uh he just tweeted earlier this week criticizing the state senator
running for Congress in California, Scott Wiener. And and he
kind of listed at the Wiener's offenses and one of them was after
October 7th, >> Yeah, dude, this was so crazy. Yeah. he
visited Israel.
Crazy.
That I saw people I saw Hasan said that on a stream and then
someone tweeted about it.
They're saying that like you have such a commitment to Israel
that you're willing to go there like when a war starts, right?
Is that not the comment? Hey, you're you're so you're so into
Israel in a general sense. You're so like you're so behind this
country that you will go there while it's a war zone. Is that
not That seems to be what the commentary is. Maybe I'm missing
The criticism was that this guy who is a
visited Israel after October 7th. What is the Oh, by the way,
that wasn't the criticism. That was a part of the criticism.
That was not the only criticism. Basically, the criticism was,
"I'm suspicious that you are not sincerely anti-Israel, right?"
This is the guy who's running on basically an anti-Israel message.
His Hasan was saying that he was it's suspicious that you're
saying you're anti-Israel, but you went to Israel after October
7th. That's That's the point, right? Am I misunder- Maybe we'll
pull it up in a second. >> the criticism?
Somebody can send the tweet. I think that's what it was.
What is the issue with that? Like why is that something that's
considered problematic? Like, "Oh, don't you know he visited
Israel after October 7th."
What am I supposed to do with that information? Why is this bad?
Uh So bizarre. Thanks so much for 94 months.
And I asked Hasan, I was like, "Why is that a problem? Who cares?"
Like that feels like anti-Semitism to be like he visited Israel.
Hasan's point of view is that Israel's kind of like South Africa
and we should be boycotting it.
Okay. I don't know. I mean, again, I think that there are a lot
of countries that are really bad. Um and if we're just focusing
on that one, I I understand why some people have concerns about
that, but I but I also have a ton of Israel criticism of Israel,
by the way. And Israel continues every day Do we talk about that
at all that Hasan just seems to think like BDS on Israel is is
morally good? Do we have any any commentary on that? Is that
So, BDS is The conclusion is is if you still think that's anti-Semitic,
the conclusion is you think BDS is anti-Semitic, which is just
a totally insane thing to say this far into like the geopolitical
situation, the the the conflict with Israel, right? Obviously.
to validate the arguments of their
And so, that kind of com- Totally free too. The most important
disagreement I have with Hasan
is that I I just I'm not sure fundamentally that he's a small
L liberal. I we jokingly said when I went God, my cost of living
is rising just
I need you guys to stop talking about Israel, though. Hutch,
these are related. These are related things.
Actually, the most topically like relevant thing to discuss in
the world right now. >> onto the What was it called? Ju-
The Jubilee show, Surrounded. And they called me a liberal millennial.
And people like Tim are like, "Are you a liberal now?" And I'm
like, "Yeah, I'm a liberal, like a small L liberal. I believe
in liberal values, right? I believe in pluralism. I believe that
we need to respect everybody.
You know, everyone in this country has the right to the religion
they want, speech they want. We have to live peaceably with people
with who have views that we think are gross. Like that's part
of being in a liberal society, sort of being in a liberal democracy.
The Bulwark is here to defend liberal democracy. I think there's
a huge threat to liberal democracy right now from the MAGA right.
That is the main threat that the country faces. And there's a
bunch of authoritarian shits on the right. They're trying to
end our this experiment, this great experiment of the of liberal
democracy we have in this country. And I spend all of my days
fighting What is this?
Oh, come on.
Please, please, Hutch, engage with that. That that's Tim's biggest
issue is what your biggest issue should be. Please engage with
that. Oh, no, he's like not paying attention. He's looking at
his chat for Twitter links. >> operations at the hot
Not my problem, you know. Those days are
Your groceries are not delivered via No, that's true. That's
true. That's true. It still causes inflation in other other areas.
That's true. That's true. I think that there's some if Wait,
now I I skipped past him saying something really stupid.
Gas prices go up, I don't give a [__] Like straight
up does not affect me.
Oh, you are totally
Oh, God. I knew he said something dumb. I knew he said something
unbelievably stupid as I skipped past that. No. No. Stop. Stop
saying it to Stop saying incredibly things, please, for the love
of God. >> Not my problem. Not my problem, you Those days
are gone.
Your groceries are not delivered via No, that's true. That's
true. It's not just your groceries. It's not just your groceries.
Operations at Hubshan gas facilities, the biggest gas processing
site. So, one Hutch thinks this has to do with his gasoline.
He thinks gasoline when he hears this. Gasoline.
That shows that he has not followed anything here. This is not
gasoline.
Or I'm pretty confident it's not at When the When they're talking
about gas processing, it's not gasoline. You refine oil into
gasoline. They're talking about natural gas, some some oil product,
some some petroleum product derivative, some some you know, something
like this. They're not talking about gasoline. >> live
it up for an attack? Is this bad?
Is this bad, you guys?
I'm not going to lie, life is good for an EV owner. Gas prices
go up, I don't give a Like, straight up don't. Uh, where do you
think your electricity comes from?
Dude, I It's actually so painful. It's actually so painful.
Not my problem. It affects everybody. It affects everybody. It
affects everybody.
Not my problem, you know. Those days are gone.
Your groceries are not delivered via No, that's true. That's
true. That's true. It still causes inflation in other other areas.
That's true. That's true.
Every area. In literally every area. >> If you take a peek
at the left, I think there's some illiberal stuff being said
on the left. I think that the China This is not what He's putting
it so mildly. He is putting it so mildly by saying it like that.
>> And it's a bunch of authoritarians on the right that
are trying to end our this experiment, this great experiment
of of liberal democracy we have in this country. And I spend
all of my days fighting that. I think that there's some If you
take a peek at the left, I think that there's some illiberal
stuff being said on the left.
He is putting it so mildly by saying it that way.
Where's the other lib What's the illiberal stuff? I I need to
For first principles, we need to go back to this. What's the
illiberal stuff being said? Cuz I've only seen Hutch criticize
people who hold the same liberal values. I've only seen him going
on Aaron. I've only seen him going on Hasan. I've not seen him
going on other people, right?
So, these people believe in electoralism. They believe in the
vote.
I've not seen him going on other people. So, who is he going
in on here? I actually don't know. >> that the China thing
is one example, but there are many where there are some folks
on the left that want kind of a strong leader of their own. I
don't want to impute that on Hasan exactly, but some of his arguments
would lead me to believe that that he's not exactly an enthusiastic
defender of liberal democracy, let's just say. So, What What
This is Listen, I really liked him, but he's he's phrasing this
so passively. We ever get to a point where there's a Hasan-style
candidate running for president and there's more of like a, you
know, sent uh a more traditional liberal candidate um running
in a Democratic primary, I will be for more of the traditional
liberal candidate, right? Obviously. And we can fight fight that
out. But like my main thing about right now about this Hasan
discourse is like none of that's happening right None of that's
happening right now. The only reason we're talking about Hasan
is because other members ostensibly of the anti-Trump coalition
have tried to turn him into a litmus test and say that people
can't be seen with him. Can't can't be seen with him. And like
I find that to be insane for a number of reasons. So, the criticism
here is going to be these people are turning Hasan into a litmus
test. They're trying to say you can't be seen with him on the
issue of Israel, that he's an anti-Semite.
Hutch should agree with that. Hutch should totally agree with
that, that Hasan's not an anti-Semite, that obviously on that
ground on those grounds, those aren't the grounds he wants to
criticize Hasan on. He should 100% agree on that, right? Not
just factually, but even if even
even just cynically, he should want to agree on those grounds
because for him, his party is moving in an anti-Israel
He's argued that you should take cynical positions, like politically
motivated positions. He should be taking a politically motivated
position here at
Like or sorry, at at worst, he should take a a politically motivated
position here. But he's Well, I I suspect he's not going to or
I probably wouldn't even be covering this at all. >> Number one,
I think the timing on that is awful. Okay? All of our energy
right now, if you are a four-level democracy, if you're against
Trump, if you think what's going on in this country is bad right
now, all of our energy should be laser-focused on undermining
this regime and bringing in more people who are potentially opponents
of the regime and
This is what so many people have said to Hutch. Hey, all of your
If you actually care about liberal democracy, your energy is
best spent going after Trump, going after the current regime,
going after and making sure everything is covered on these people.
People understand that there is no way you could possibly vote
for these people. That this is the worst thing to happen to your
country in decades.
Right? So, stop going after Hasan. Start going after the Trump
administration. >> our numbers, right? There's strength
in numbers. Whether that be at the No Kings in Protest, whether
that be at the midterms this coming year, whether that be in
2028, like we need as many people as possible to push back this
threat that I believe seriously is an existential threat to the
country. That's me, okay? And so, right now in this moment, when
Donald Trump is taking the entire world headlong into an energy
crisis, where he's like engaged in a lawless war that he gave
a nonsense speech about last night that it was basically incomprehensible.
We don't even know what the objective is. Like when when they
are killing people in the streets of Minneapolis, like this is
not the moment to nitpick some streamer who also opposes us.
It's just Does Hasan oppose like Iran in a meaningful way? >> It's not
crisis. It's an existential threat to the Hold
[laughter] on. What did he say there precisely? the streets of
Minneapolis, like this is not the moment to nitpick some streamer
who also opposes us. Does Hasan oppose like Iran in a Wait. Did
he just hear killing in the streets? Did he just hear killing
the streets and he didn't realize in me at No, cuz how do you
hear killing the streets of Minneapolis and think Iran? Hold
on. taking the back this threat that I believe seriously is an
existential threat to the country. That's me, okay? And so, right
now in this moment, when Donald Trump is taking the entire world
headlong into an energy crisis, where he's like engaged in a
lawless war that he gave a nonsense speech about last night that
it was basically incomprehensible. We don't even know what the
objective is. Like when when they are killing people in the streets
of Minneapolis, like this is not the moment to nitpick some streamer
who also opposes us. Oh, no. Oh, no.
Does Hasan oppose like Iran in a meaningful way?
Oh, what?
How do people watch this guy? How do people watch? How do they
watch? How do they watch? He's not even paying
at all.
That's crazy.
crazy, man.
Isn't half of his audience A-logs? No, Hutch gets like hundreds
of viewers. I think Hutch operates around 1,000 or 1,300 concurrent.
No, there's no way it's like mostly A-logs. That is not the case.
No. Surely the chat isn't also brain dead, right? Surely. Surely
somebody's going to point out that's not what was said.
Dude, one Hasan absolutely would oppose would oppose like that
the Oh, what would you say? The um the authoritarian crackdowns
on protesters. He absolutely would oppose that.
But two, that's not even the point. This guy is saying And by
the way, Hutch is a perfect microcosm here. Tim is saying, "Listen,
when they're killing people in the streets of Minneapolis, maybe
Hasan Piker's views on Israel's on Israel are not the things
we should be focusing on." And Hutch goes, "Does Hasan even oppose
Iran?"
He is like the exact thing that Tim is sort of denouncing and
saying is silly.
He is that exact thing.
He's proving Tim's point perfectly
in the moment.
That's crazy. >> crisis. It's an existential threat to
the country. That's me, okay? And so, right now in this moment,
when Donald Trump is taking the entire world headlong into an
energy crisis, where he's like engaged in a lawless war that
he gave a nonsense speech about last night that it was basically
incomprehensible. We don't even know what the objective is. Like
when when they are killing people
I think he's saying he opposes Trump and his peeps. Dude, uh
yeah. It's One one person barely got that. >> of Minneapolis,
like this is not the moment to nitpick some I heard him wrong.
streamer who also opposes us.
I mean
>> Like Donald not going to stop being Donald Trump. Like
Donald Trump is not going to stop being awful and using these
agencies and institutions
as weapons. Um Wait, he's not He's not going to say something
even more ridiculous.
He's not going to say, "Well, I can't do anything about Trump,
so I'm not even going to talk about it." There's no way he's
going to say that, right? There's no possible way cuz that's
what it sounds like. >> This administration is not going
to stop like arbitrarily detaining people and and perhaps like
accidentally deporting American citizens. Like that's not going
to stop
for the rest of this administration. And so, if we were to use
Tim's logic, there would never be a good time to
uh confront Hasan or or challenge his rhetoric. He's saying don't
challenge Hasan. He literally said This is the argument, Hutch.
Oh my god. This is the argument Tim is making.
Going after Hasan on Israel when Israel is consistently acting
like totally monstrous freaks on the global stage is insane.
That's an insane stand to take. Oh, stop Stop, anti-Semite. The
anti-Semitism. Maybe Israel shouldn't be, you know, killing a
bunch of people. Maybe Israel should stop bombing a bunch of
stuff. And Hutch is like, "Whoa.
When will I ever criticize Hasan if not now?" Well, probably
a time that it doesn't make you look like a like you support
genocide, right? Like you support an ethnic cleansing in Southern
Lebanon. Probably at any other time you could have criticized
Hasan compared to now cuz I'm sure Tim is Tim's obviously unaware
of what Hutch has done up to this point. But he's saying like
right now, this is probably the absolute worst time to go after
Hasan over Israel. You look insane. And the other part of the
other important part of this is that Hasan's not going to stop
actively trying to sabotage the Democratic Party in its current
state.
That's what he's all about. Like he's chasing this
Wait, but don't you understand that if the Dems go down this
anti-war path in this exact way, if they go down this anti-war
path, doesn't Hutch understand that basically Hasan loses all
credibility if he's not willing to acknowledge and and basically
revel in the idea that the Dems will be like pro-defunding Israel?
Hasan looks insane. If Hasan's not immediately like, "Oh, I'm
voting for all of these guys." Right? That is the number one
thing. By the way, Hasan phone banked for Biden. Hasan in 2020
was all leaning on Biden.
What changed in 2024?
Israel. What is Tim's argument? What is Matt Iglesias' argument?
What is everybody's argument? It is, "Hey, we actually shouldn't
be supporting Israel anyway. So, give them Israel, and then we
get like their support." That's the argument.
This fantasy of a left-wing Tea Party that is not unfolding.
Uh it's just not.
And so,
Hassan's kind of sabotage
is is just inevitable. You know, we're going to we're going to
make it to these midterms, and he's still going to be doing the
same thing. He's still going to be doing the same shenanigans.
He didn't do those shenanigans you're referring to. He did not
do those in
He didn't do them.
What are we talking about?
But do you want to be the anti-Semitic party? That's basically
what the conversation actually is, and they just keep trying
to recenter it around Hassan instead of having the actual conversation.
It's not going to work. If Hassan was able to meaningfully engage
voters and
advance advance candidates that could do could actually win elections,
like win primaries and then win elections in competitive seats,
then he would have so much more value. But he can't. He doesn't
He can't do that. He and his movement, all they can do is snipe
a few wins in really safe blue seats. That's it.
That is it, okay? None of his But the trade that's being proposed
between these two groups is essentially, "Hey, if you're willing
to play ball on this Israel thing, then we'll actually go in
multiple places. We won't just do like the safe blue seats. When
when if we lose a primary in like a purple seat, we'll vote for
the purple candidate.
We'll advocate voting for the purple candidate." That's the trade
that's being proposed right now. That's the trade that worked
in previous like previous elections. In 2024, it didn't work
because obviously in 2024,
we had an issue with Israel. Like these people were like, "I
principally cannot vote for people who are continuing to fund
Israel given what's happening."
So, Tim is saying, "Well, give them that issue, and then we move
forward as a coalition, as a big tent coalition." Cuz one, that
issue is basically already decided. That's Dems are against Israel
now. Israel's been doing this stuff for long enough. They've
been doing it transparently enough, right? Blowing up buildings,
uh ethnically cleansing, killing civilians. They've been doing
this stuff for a long enough period of time in front of the entire
globe that most Democrats are actually just against them now.
So, why not lean into that? Wow. His preferred candidates are
actually competitive
in light red, purple, or light blue districts. They're just not.
That's not Dude, Hutch is Hutch is like making faces and arguing
against total shadows. This isn't what Tim is saying.
Hutch is literally arguing against a shadow right now. That Tim
didn't say anything like this. He didn't say they're competitive
in purple districts. He didn't say anything about that. He's
making a point about how stupid it is to go after these people
on Israel. in light red, purple, or light blue districts. They're
just not. That's not their strong suit. And so, where is the
value? Like why are we Why is Hassan such a critical part of
this coalition?
If that's the case. Like what is his actual value that he's he's
bringing
I just don't get this logic. I just don't understand this logic.
He's got a massive audience. He's got a massive like pulpit that
he can basically say, "Hey, go I Here's the thing. You get really
mad that he hasn't supported some candidate. You You accused
him of like basically causing problems for the Democrats in the
last election, right?"
If that pulpit is important, if it's important whether it goes
for you or against you, then
why not why not just give something up that you should give up
anyway and have it go for you?
What is the What is the reason behind like not wanting to just
take that trade? What's the worst case scenario here, right?
The worst case scenario to me is
Yeah, the worst case scenario is well, it doesn't work, and they
I don't know. It goes against you. He He goes against you. You
know that You know now that you gave him Israel to never trust
this guy again. Is that the worst case scenario?
It feels like that's the worst case scenario there. Is Is Hassan
actually does betray you and and basically he advocates against
voting for Dems.
You know, they Dems give him Israel. They They say, "Okay, we're
not going to support Israel. We're actually going to support
defunding Israel." And then
Hassan still advocates against the the candidate in the general
election.
I can't imagine this happening. But let's say that does happen.
Well, now you know for later. I would say almost nobody would
argue that's not going to The argument from everybody around
Hutch would be something like, "Well, no, we can't give Hassan
anything. We can't give him that. No, we can't do that, right?"
Anyway, yeah, I know I know I know. I know he posted another
video, and we will check it out shortly after this. But I'm going
to check out the Hutch reaction.
Anyway, I'm Dude, I should have watched this before stream. I
could have laid out the arguments a little bit better,
yeah, it's There is no There is no downside to basically just
not criticizing Hassan over Israel. That's all Tim is really
advocating for is just don't criticize Hassan over his Israel
position. Tim is actively criticizing Hassan over other positions.
Right? Hey, he's way too He gets way too cozy with China. Well,
I don't like some of these things about him. I'm not sure if
he's very But he's saying, "Don't go after him for Israel. It
looks really stupid to go after him for Israel."
Platner is right there, Hutch. Yeah, that's true. I mean, I'm
not saying it never happens, but
It's rare. And also,
Platner's in a purple race, and Platner's winning, and Platner
might do quite well in a general election. It's It's rare. It
is rare. Platner is not exactly Hassan's preferred candidate,
by the way. I think doesn't Hassan have issues with Platner?
I don't think Hassan is a big Platner stan.
Hassan is a massive Platner stan. Hassan is a absolutely massive
Platner stan to the point that he's Is that not the genesis of
his fight his most recent fight with Bad Empanada? Is Hassan
supporting Platner, and Hassan kept saying to Bad Empanada fans,
"You guys shut the [__] up. Stop talking about this.
Go watch Bad Empanada if you actually think this." I'm pretty
sure this is what he thought with Bad Empanada over.
>> And on top of that, it's particularly intractable progressive
streamer that reaches an audience of people that the Democrats
are struggling with and and and that right now is a particularly
ripe moment to act. >> I mean, you know, yeah, Democrats
are probably going to struggle with the you know, Democrats are
just as evil as Republicans demographic.
Yeah, they're probably going to struggle with that group a little
bit more relative to Have you thought about not supporting the
country like
unquestionably and uncritically like all the time supporting
the country that is doing an ethnic cleansing actively right
now? I Have you thought about trying it? I just It hasn't ever
been tried. Does Does nobody think like, "What if we tried it?"
How does nobody think that? What if we just tried it? We could
just try supporting the country or not supporting the country
that's doing an ethnic cleansing
right now?
At this precise moment in time. Why not just give it a shot?
>> That doesn't mean that we should be spending a lot of
time trying to come up with ways to
uh you know, create reliable coalition partners and voters from
that group. Uh that seems like a dubious use of um resources.
had them. People that are opposed to this war,
I actually don't know that anybody is arguing that you should
be putting resources towards this. I think they're basically
saying you just They're saying you shouldn't say that like it's
impossible. We shouldn't work with these people. Like you don't
have to put resources towards supporting them. Nobody's asking
you to donate to their candidates. Nobody's really asking for
anything except just stop trying to like uh stop trying to jump
on the clips that have been put out on Israel and cancel this
guy. I think that's like basically it, right? Like stop putting
the resources into
fighting against him. Just put the resources into something else.
People that are upset about Israel's prosecution of the war in
Gaza. People that are upset about Israel's in Hassan is really
good at reaching people who loathe the Democratic Party. We should,
you know, try to make bedfellows with them or on on our involvement
in this war in Iran. People that
are upset at the bi- most mostly Republican, let's be honest,
but somewhat bipartisan like military-industrial complex that
has gotten us into war after war. Like there are a lot of people
out there that are against that. I've actually posted videos
of some of them Jill Stein and by a bunch of far left streamers
and a bunch of people that convinced them that Kamala was going
to get us into a war when really Trump was. We all saw that clearly.
We can pat ourselves on the back. But right now in
Sorry, we just got a gay face right now. >> streamers and
a bunch of people that convinced them that Kamala was going to
get us into a war when really Trump was. We all saw that clearly.
We can pat ourselves on the back. But right now in this moment
when we're in this war when people are feeling a lot of pain,
this needs to be the moment to say, "Come on in." to everybody,
particularly people that are that are ranging from skeptical
to hostile of this war and of actions in the Middle East. This
is the moment for that. And Hassan talks to some of those people.
So, to pick this moment, a month into the war, to pick this fight,
it's crazy. [laughter] It's crazy. And if you are a centrist,
He's got a K. That's the core thesis of what's going on here.
It's insane to pick a fight on Israel right now. Totally [__]
insane.
That's like irrefutable. It's obviously true. There's certainly
no way Hutch could fight with that, right? That is an insane
time to pick the fight to defend Israel is in the month where
they're doing an ethnic cleansing, in the month where this war
has started. This is the absolute worst time. >> True.
Hey, listen, some of us have been fighting that fight for years,
okay? We didn't just start fighting this fight in the last like
month or two. It's just that mainstream media caught up to the
online discourse for some reason. Hutch here nice point on that
Wiki panel was that there's a lot of left-wingers with more impetus
with a more impetus liberal that could be pulled away from Hassan's
sphere into a
There's a lot of hot young women who are really dumb, and if
they just had somebody to explain things to them, they would
understand. Just like Erudite did, right? They're just very dumb.
Naime is very dumb. Taliesin is very dumb. Or sorry, Tilly's
very dumb, and Emmy, Charlie, all very dumb, not very steeped
in their political opinions, haven't read anything. They don't
really know anything. They're basically just libs.
They They totally love Israel. They don't just don't realize
it yet. Perhaps if we could explain just how many missiles are
stored below hospitals and schools, they'll begin to understand
that Israel isn't evil after all. Maybe. >> broader little
coalition. If you have a URL and a timestamp, feel free to link
that in the chat. We can give it a gander. Just They don't understand
just how inherently violent and
how inherently physically and violent Muslims are. Right? They
are inherently, according to Erudite,
physically and violent. They just don't get it yet. If once they
get it, they'll understand. Once Once they get it, they
they'll know why we support Israel, >> some sympathies
to that, obviously. If you're in a moderate coalition >> and
you want to pick a fight with the left wing of the Democratic
Party, let me tell you there's a lot of potential options there.
I mean, John Lovett and I were talking about this this week about
the mismanagement of California. They're trying to build a moderate
rail there. They're not even breaking ground till 2041. You know,
we could go down the list. There are a bunch of things the American
people don't like the Democrats right now. And if you want to
fight with the left of the party from center, again, this I wouldn't
think would be the moment to do that, but if you wanted to try
to, you know, move the party to the center on something on an
issue, there are a bunch of them out there that the public would
be on your side of. To pick Israel and Hasan [__]
right now as the issue to fight about, to advance the interests
of the center of the party, all you're doing is undermining the
credibility of the center of the party, right? Okay, he just
made it incredibly clear. There is no possible way you could
misunderstand what Tim is saying
Literally, so many issues that you could try to pull the party
back towards the center on. Just do not pick Israel. Israel's
the one I'm begging you not to pick cuz you look insane.
Surely Surely Hutch engages now. >> All you 90% of the
Democrats voted against this war.
And the popularity of this war and of Israel and of Middle Eastern
conflicts is going down by the minute within the Democratic coalition.
I I just don't know how I feel about this logic, you guys. So
bizarre. Thanks so much for 94 months. Can I get you for that?
Thank you, buddy. Okay, that's almost engaging. >> There's
a couple things that I agree with him on. Um I think a lot of
the attacks that I've seen on Hasan have been unfair.
I will just fully acknowledge that. Like some of the clips that
they're choosing,
I don't know if they're deliberately obfuscating or deliber-
Oh, sh- Wait, what? Oh, no. >> dishonest, but some of the
clips I think are being blown way out of proportion.
And when you attack Hasan like that, I think that only makes
Hasan stronger. So, I wouldn't advise doing that. Um So, I don't
think he's wrong about that, but I By the way, Hutch explicitly
blowing up Wicker, explicitly blowing up Not So Erudite here.
Not So Erudite keeps continuing continuously, okay? She continuously
tries to blow up the inbred Orthodox people comment, which is
nothing, total nothingburger, okay? That's the That's got to
be the clip he's talking about.
There's one other one, which is the I don't think these matter
in the context of the broader genocide. There's that one. The
pig dog slur. Yeah, the pig dog
Dude, it's
it's just wild. There are so many people who are blowing up all
of the wrong clips for all of the wrong reasons.
So, Hutch calling them out right now. Hutch is saying, "Hey,
guys, it's kind of embarrassing."
And Hutch of all people saying this, "Hey, when you like myopically
focus on this guy and blow up clips that don't mean what you
say they mean, it helps
Hutch of all people is saying this. I think I don't know. I question
Tim's judgment on now is not the time to challenge Hasan. I I
really question that logic. It's never on Israel on Israel. Stop
trying to challenge Hasan on Israel.
That's what Third Way is doing explicitly. They are trying to
use the Israel issue. They're trying to use anti-Semitism as
a cudgel against Hasan. That is what is bad. >> bad time,
I think, to confront that element because they are destructive.
They are political arsonists. They're serious about stopping
Republicans. That is not their goal. Their goal is the complete
takeover takeover of the Democratic Party. Which I'm not even
saying it's immoral to have that goal, okay? That's
Quite frankly, that's politics. If If especially in a two-party
system that's
>> a progressive person,
of course you would have the goal of taking over the Democratic
Party. Um that's that's democracy, you know? Like that that's
democracy. There's nothing like wrong with that. Um You've actually
said repeatedly that Hold on. I actually need to back it up before
I make any crazy >> Which I'm not even saying it's immoral
to have that goal, okay? That's
Quite frankly, that's politics. If If especially in a two-party
system You definitely said it's bad and you're going to fight
him because he has this
If If you're a progressive person,
of course you would have the goal of taking over the Democratic
Party. Um that's that's democracy, you know? Like that that's
democracy. There's nothing like wrong with that. Um even if I
disagree with some of their positions
some of their ideologies, some of their principles. Hey, like
this is a contest. And if they want to go out there and try to
convince people that they should be in charge of the Democratic
Party, they have every right to do that. But that's that's not
really I think like the big issue. Um the big issue is that that
thing for them is the highest order goal. Like that is that's
the top of their list of things that they want to
Is this like really hostile Well, no, that's Hold on. That's
not the top of their list, but it becomes the top of their list
when they have higher goals, right? They have actual other goals,
but they can't accomplish any of those goals without more power.
So, they have to obtain more power to accomplish any goal, right?
So, it's like, well, if you could just pick something from the
top of the list, I'm sure they would pick like an issue, a a
policy thing,
I'm sure if you could just say, "Well, you get one wish." They
wouldn't go, "Well, I wish for more power right now." They'd
say, "Oh, universal health care." Oh, we could just have universal
universal health care immediately. You promise me it can't be
undone? Universal health care. Easy. Easy, instant, right?
But in terms of well, they have to build enough power to get
those things accomplished. Well, yeah, they're going to start
doing this. >> take over the Democratic Party and they
basically want to destroy it as it currently is and replace it
with their
like progressive vision or leftist
And I don't think that that is a
tenable thing to prioritize over beating Republicans. That's
what I think is like really destructive. If you don't understand
how bad the Republican Party is, how dangerous they've become,
how much damage they do when we give them power. >> And
if you haven't reached the conclusion that we need to do everything
to stop Republicans from winning seats, if you haven't arrived
at that conclusion by now,
I I don't know how much worse it could get for people to understand
the stakes. I I just don't understand.
Destiny is edgy, Hasan is dangerous.
Uh you call it the Hulk, you can call it
I I just don't understand the concept
that Hasan is dangerous.
It Well, I do understand it. It all comes back to this lie. And
maybe I have to go and and watch this thing again and put like
a video out or something cuz I feel like there's you can go watch
that Deep Program episode and and pick it apart and say exactly
what's happening. And it is not him saying, "I'm just only going
to lie about what I'm saying."
Which is what they advertise it as being. They advertise it as
being, "I'm obviously just going to lie all the time because
uh if I told the truth, nobody would ever agree with me." That's
what they advertise it as. It's the It's the Deep Program interview.
And it is It's like a lie. You go back and listen to it. He's
not saying that I'm going to hide my power level and I just I
really am one of you guys and eventually we'll take over. He's
saying like, "Well, I disagree with you guys, but regardless,
like if if I disagree with you guys and you guys end up being
correct and I'm wrong, then the worst thing that you could do
by supporting me and like like agreeing with me and helping me
in my project, the worst thing that could happen is we get closer
to you guys anyway." Right? The worst thing that could happen
like even in the case where we don't ever get to what you guys
are doing, like my project helps you. It's It's just goofy that
it's been presented as something else, something that it's not.
>> theory of politics, meaning launching bad attacks at
bad faith actors allows them to use those bad attacks to grow
stronger. It's like the Doomsday the character Doomsday in Batman
v Superman.
I'm sure there's other characters like this, but
Uh if you if you attack Hasan, yeah, if you attack him with bad
faith attacks, then it does make him stronger, so you shouldn't
do that. Like there's plenty of Hasan quotes in context
that are bad enough. So, you don't need to do that. And I So,
I think it's kind of lazy. If I had to guess what's going on
is people like Jake Jake Tapper, they have their production team,
and that team's job is to look up information about the subject.
Where did Jake Tapper get all of those quo- Where did Jake Tapper
get literally everything he used?
It came from closer to home, Hutch. It came from closer to home.
It feels weird that you can't acknowledge that. Come on, man.
>> reporting. And those people are just doing kind of like
cursory Google searches, and they're finding Reddit posts and
these kinds of pithy sort of
Well, the weird thing is is Dan's legitimately out of this stuff.
Dan's legitimately out of this stuff, okay? Like he he doesn't
seem to be engaging in anything like what he was before, okay?
And I don't know what the reason is for that like broadly, but
he's just not doing it anymore. I think he basically just didn't
get support. And it's funny cuz I somebody linked me a clip today
of
basically I think like Destiny and Mouton saying, "Well, Dan
could be useful right now and be attacking Hasan." It's like
they're trying to get him to go back to going after Hasan.
I'm just like
Does Hutch know that? Does Hutch know where Jake Tapper got those
clips? Cuz it's like very obvious, and it just seems weird that
he's like saying this,
>> Doesn't Dan still talk to you? Yes.
Well, kind of. He think He thinks I'm like scheming against him,
I think. Which I'm not. I'm
Okay, but
he does.
It's just it's weird that Hutch is saying, "Oh, he just blamed
it on Jake Tapper." It's like, dude, Jake Tapper got those clips
from a certain place. And uh so, it's kind of lazy. Honestly,
I would I think I would be really good at that job.
Honestly, I think I would be really good at that job. Like if
you if you gave me an on-air talent,
and it was my job to research topics for them that relate to
online discourse, I think I would be really good at that
But I think that's what's happening. Um and and if you if you
do that, then I think you're probably going to make Hasan stronger
if the if the attacks are like blatantly bad faith or lazy.
Are you going to apply to be Jake Tapper's Hasan specialist?
No, I don't even mean just like specializing in Hasan, but just
online discourse is like a different beast and you have to be
pretty online to understand a lot of the lore and yeah.
And so, for you to be like, "Now, just hold on. I don't want
to talk because there's a chance that hey, there's like a tiny
tiny chance that Hutch goes and starts helping Jake Tapper and
I think that just leads to good things in the world. If if Sorry,
it's that Hutch Hutch will help Jake Tapper. If Hutch is the
person doing research for Jake Tapper, that only leads to good
things. That only leads to good outcomes, okay? I think that
would be a very good thing for everybody. Well, not for Jake
Tapper, but for everybody else. >> we as the centrist establishment
serious types want to exile far leftists from here cuz he has
some impure thoughts about Israel. It's like all you're doing
is making him more powerful. All you're doing is is making people
think you're a bigger idiot. Yeah. To pick right now? Well,
hold on. To have this military conflict is going down by the
minute within the Democratic coalition. And so, for you to be
like, "Now,
like I just want to point out that this group of people, they
cannot
at least the the like Destiny erudite stuff going back to that
panel. I don't think they can give this away, even though this
is obviously true. They can't go, "Well, yeah, this is bad faith
and it's happening in a bad faith way." Destiny has said that
Hasan would nuke Israel if he was elected. That like he believes
Hasan wants to nuke Israel, okay? And that Myron Gaines is a
lesser
Like you can't take this position now as one of those two people.
You maybe take it as Hutch that like, "Oh, it is silly to go
after him for his anti-Semitism. That's like not very good. That's
not a very good attack."
Right? But nobody else can follow Nobody can follow Hutch where
he's going. And I don't know if he maybe doesn't know that or
what's going on here. >> we as the centrist establishment
serious types want to exile a far leftist from here cuz he has
some impure thoughts about Israel. It's like all you're doing
is making him more Uh I think that's a bit reductive. I don't
know if it's just because he has impure thoughts about Israel.
That's a bit reductive. powerful. All you're doing is is making
people think you're a bigger
That's what they're complaining about. That's what That's what
that whole panel was complaining about. Hutch has said the nuke
things, too? No way. Find me a clip of Hutch saying that. I don't
believe Hutch said that. Come on. Hutch is smarter than that.
Come on. Hutch is a little bit smarter than that, no? He wouldn't
say that. That's an insane thing to say. >> This is like
might This is like might equals right, but in an online sense.
Like Hasan is so so big and his audience is so large and he has
so much like motion on social media
that it's almost like Tim saying that you're you should be you're
kind of forced to have some kind of an alliance with this person.
You just can't really ignore ignore him in that way or try to
excise him in that It is kind of like might might equals right,
you know? Right now, to have this And it is truly it's like madness.
And the entire country is moving the other direction. It's moving
We can just be honest. It's moving Hasan's direction on the on
the question of Israel question of Israel and you're like, "Yeah,
we're going to pick a fight with him on that?
Right now? When Bibi and Trump are careening the world economy,
they got us in this war they don't know how to get out of. They're
doing war crimes, shooting bombing schools, girl schools. What
are you doing? What are you doing? If Tim's point is that uh
with influence, you know, the centrist think tanks
like them attacking You see, Tim has reiterated his point like
eight different times. Is Hutch just now going to get Tim's point?
He's just now
going to get Tim's point. Tim said this like he's reiterated
his point multiple times and Hutch [clears throat] is going to
go, "Wait, if Tim's point is just like that we shouldn't really
be focusing on Israel, well then then I like maybe agree >> Hasan
over Israel is tactically stupid. I don't know if I disagree
with that. I think Tim might be right about that.
Like if you're going to go after Hasan, I mean there are some
of his Israel takes that I think are bad and worth
But there's so many other things to go
that don't bog the conversation down in like Israel-Palestine
stuff, which is just a bit of a quagmire, I think.
That It's not a quagmire. It's actually People just go, "Oh,
it's a quagmire. I don't really Guys, it's such a boring topic.
It's like a total quagmire. We're not even going to get anywhere."
No, everybody's getting somewhere. You don't like where we're
getting. That's what you don't like. You You hate where it's
going. So, you go, "Oh, it's a quagmire. I don't know if I can
talk about it, man. I just I It's like It's so hard to talk about."
No, it's not. It's actually incredibly easy to talk about right
now.
It's never been easier to talk about this issue because one side
has shown themselves. They've shown their ass.
Totally. Sorry, there's a different clip of apparently the nuke
point got made. Hold on. >> Do you trust that he would
not he would not nuke Israel?
Do you trust that he would not help
invade Taiwan?
Uh I don't trust the China thing. No, no, no. The China thing
is actually a good point. The The nuking Israel thing is total
derangement. Complete and utter
All right. Total complete entire entirely derangement. The idea
that he might
He wouldn't like help He wouldn't give China like weapons, but
I think he would absolutely look to reduce
America's presence in the Pacific Islands and that would help
China at some point, absolutely. Hold on. There's apparently
a third clip or we're finding a third clip over here.
What is this one?
Hasan [__] nukes. I think he might nuke Israel. I'm
not going to lie to you guys. I do think he might do that. Totally
deranged. Completely deranged. >> Get it. We did this already.
5 years ago a bunch of liberals were like, "You can't go on Joe
Rogan. He has some bad
I just like we can't do this again. Okay? You can't do this again.
This is If you personally don't like Hasan [__] that's
fine. Me and Hasan disagree on a bunch of stuff. We're going
to argue about a bunch of stuff over the next few years, the
rest of our lives, as long as we're streaming. We'll be arguing
about various things and that's fine. People can follow me or
agree with me sometimes, him sometimes, maybe some people agree
with me all the time, him all the time. That's That's Like what
is the utility of trying to shun him and his audience right now
if you're in the pro-democracy coalition?
I don't know about shunning, but I think
no shunning. Be honest. Shunning.
Don't say I don't know about shunning. That is not where your
disagreement comes with this. Your disagreement is on way different
lines. You do believe in shunning him. Be serious. Be honest.
Do not lie. Okay?
So, now Hutch is going to lay out Tim asked the question perfectly.
Hutch is going to lay out his points, okay? >> of confronting
them is to
head off something that is surely coming. Like this Here's Here's
what is going to happen, okay? Um the electorate are going to
slightly prefer more normie Democrats in races in these midterms.
And the Hasan left are going to only try to advance their preferred
candidates. They're not going to make any Which again, I ask
the question like what is the nature of their contribution
to the anti-MAGA fight? Okay, so then it's a primary. So, you
have to argue that after the primary, they will go, "Actually,
because we couldn't get our candidate through, we actually won't
support this anymore."
Yet there are so many people around Hasan who've explicitly said
they do not believe that's the thing they that they do not believe
in that. They want to support the like the Democratic Party no
matter what on the next ticket.
So, I just I don't get it. And by the way, the only way they
got off this time The only way they basically pulled back from
that this time is over Israel-Palestine. Is over like a principled
issue.
Which Tim is proposing that you give ground on. If they're If
all they do is promote candidates that pass their purity tests
in really safe blue seats,
what value are they actually bringing
They just promoted Kat Abu Gazzaleh who failed purity tests for
them, explicitly.
Kat failed a purity test on Hasan's stream live. She's He's listening
to her talk. She fails a purity test and Hasan goes, "Dude, she's
the candidate. She's who we got to support. We're supporting
her." Right?
They just supported somebody who failed a butt like a major purity
test for anybody in the more like pro-China camp.
Even Mike from PA came out and said, "Oh, actually I'm going
to give up on my purity test. I'm going to support her, too."
How are they actually hurting the coalition? I don't really understand
the value there.
here's another prediction that I think is a pretty safe prediction.
The American voters, primary voters for the Democratic Party
in 2028, are going to pick a more kind of centristy normie establishment
Dem. It's It's going to be Kamala or it's going to be Gavin Newsom.
You know, it's going to be like It's not going to be like a Bernie
type
And chances I think right now, things could change, but chances
are good at right now that they're going to run a campaign that
is more rhetorically
than previous campaigns.
I think that the Democratic Party and these candidates are probably
going to be a little freaked out thinking about the numbers that
we see over and over again about how a lot of the country think
that the Democratic Party had become too extreme, become too
left-wing. And so, I think we're going to see uh another campaign
that looks a little bit like Kamala's in 2024 where um you know,
she wasn't running on like right-wing policy, just to be clear.
But she wasn't running on kind of big bold progressive policy,
either. She wasn't running on a public option. She wasn't running
on universal health care. She wasn't running on, you know, paid
family leave. Um She wasn't running on like economic
And that is probably going to happen again in 2028.
And the Hasan left are going to be very very antagonistic about
that candidate.
And so, from my perspective, I think it's better to have these
conversations now because you're kind of getting ahead of it,
you know?
So, the Democrats don't have to get rid of its alliance with
Zionism? Is this the goal? Didn't Kamala lose in no small part
due to their endless support of Israel? I just wish you guys
would stop making Israel
uh Who cares about Israel, guys? Israel isn't even in our country.
Actually, fantastic point, Hutch. That's what everybody's arguing
for is that you shouldn't make Israel an important issue. You
should not give them money. You should not fund them at all.
Right? Don't give them anything. Don't give them a qual qualitative
military edge. Don't give them anything.
And yeah, don't make them an issue. They don't have to be involved
in American politics at all. That's what everybody
Well, but not like that though, right? Not like that. Not like,
oh, we shouldn't make them an issue. We shouldn't actually try
to purity test people on Israel. We should just like never talk
about Israel and the the things they do. That's more what he
means, okay? It's actually really bad optics that we continue
to support Israel through all of this, guys. So, if you could
just not mention it, that would be really helpful. Could you
just not mention our support for this genocidal regime?
For this genocidal not just regime, but entire political cast.
Right? That that every leader would be continuing the exact policies
that they're doing right now. Every leader that they that they're
running all think this exact same thing.
without without exception, even the center-left guy. >> Like,
I want to beat Republicans in elections. And I question the strategy
of picking one of the least salient
and most divisive issues
to be the center point of the intraparty
debate that happens around primary time. Why would we do that?
Why the Why
Because people are getting ethnically cleansed. Because people
are getting killed every day you fail to talk about it because
of America's contributions to
That's why they want to talk about it,
How does he not understand why people want to talk about it?
I just don't get why you'd make this a center cuz America is
funding a genocide is the point they're making.
Either dispute that point or off.
He's not even attempting to dispute this. He's just going, I
don't see why we'd make it a big deal.
Cuz most people think like wantonly killing everybody around
you is a big deal. And I don't know. Most people have a functioning
moral compass, it seems. >> we do that. It's not that you
shouldn't do any advocacy whatsoever when it comes to Palestinians
and uh a state for Palestinians and sovereignty for them and
and these kinds of things. Like, that's fine, but making that
the center
of the intraparty debate
when it is, you know, one of the most divisive and one of the
least salient issue for voters, that's just bad
Why do you think it's divisive
It's not divisive for Democrats.
It's becoming less divisive divisive by the day.
The real question here is how do you
And I I don't know if Hutch even realizes this, but I think the
real problem that people are running into, like the the actual
like Zionists who have run this way as politicians, is they have
no way to explain
why they've had the position they've had for so long. And that
as soon as they give up, like, oh, we shouldn't fund Israel because
of what they're doing, then it goes then it's going to flip to,
well, why did you keep doing it for so long? They know that that's
the next question voters are going to ask them, and they have
no answer to that question.
So, it's not that it's not that they it's not that they're avoiding
a divisive issue. They it's an existential issue for them. But
they made it. American politicians made it an existential issue
for them, okay? That wasn't anybody else. That wasn't Hassan.
That wasn't anyone, okay? American politicians made it an existential
They're the ones who continued on with the policies they did.
That's not on Hassan. That's not on anybody else, okay? That's
why I think most people don't want to talk about it. It's cuz
they realize there's no way to explain their position for as
long as they've held it.
That's what I think.
That's just really bad strategy to me. Uh DNC 2024 autopsy would
make the issue more salient. They aren't releasing [clears throat]
it on purpose, Hutch.
here's my take on that.
Um there were some reporting, when was it, about a month ago
that the DNC went to like hundreds of different groups. Among
those groups were Palestinian
in those discussions, it was established that Kamala's position
on Israel-Gaza hurt her. It like lost her votes.
But number one, we already knew that. And number two,
and I mentioned this yesterday on the stream, that was a no-win
situation. Like, no matter what position she took on Israel-Palestine,
it was going to lose her votes. And so, I don't know if if it
would have lost her more votes if she would have taken a position
of arms embargo, let's alienate Israel.
But respectfully, of course, Naru, respectfully, that doesn't
change the fact that the issue itself is not particularly salient
with voters. There's no evidence of this. There's no evidence
that a meaningful amount of Democratic primary voters and Democratic
general voters are particularly motivated by Israel-Palestine
when they go to vote. It's not even a top 15 issue for the vast
majority of voters. Okay, but that doesn't mean Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. That's not answering the main question. The main
question is, what do the what do what do they want?
So, you could say, well, it's not even a main issue for most
voters, so we shouldn't talk about it. What Why you shouldn't
talk about it is because it's a solved issue for most Right?
Most voters are against Israel. No, he's saying he's saying that
they they don't make or break their votes based on Israel policy.
And in fact,
that seems like by design that he's pointing it out. That's bad.
That looks bad to most people. To to most average, maybe non-Americans
even, okay? The fact that it doesn't make a difference that you
support this country and what they use that support for is to
kill and ethnically cleanse people, right? That looks bad that
it doesn't bother you. But he's saying, oh, well, it doesn't
actually flip elections. That could be true. But okay, so what's
another issue? Let's say that DEI, let's say Democrats ran a
hundred hundred percent they think DEI is good.
If you ran anti-DEI and went, well, nobody you ran against what
the entire party wants, right? But you go, well, nobody's going
to make it's not going to make or break an election for anybody.
Wouldn't that be right? That would be completely That would be
completely moronic. You shouldn't say, well, it doesn't make
or break the election for anybody when your entire party's on
one side of the issue.
You That's your side of the issue. That's what your party wants
you to represent. He's like making a horrible argument for why
this issue shouldn't be talked about. Literally, it should be
talked about. If the party is that heavily in support of one
side of the issue versus the other, then the lack of the parties
the lack of party willingness to engage with that issue and take
that position is concerning and should be talked about. >> You
can be sad about that, and that's fine. You can think more people
should care, and that's fine. I'm not saying that you shouldn't
feel that way. You can feel whatever you want, but that doesn't
change the facts. Um I have to go to the bathroom real quick,
guys.
Give me just a few minutes, and I'll be right back, okay? I love
you. I'll be right back. Okay, so people that are totally out
Yeah, I was told that basically nothing cool happens after he
comes back from